tiffany millionen englische of work hard
reset to me everything von youth for
free because of you und bevor ich es
vergesse sie wollen weitermachen
abonnieren kanal ganz ganz wichtig bald
sind wir eine vision deswegen ist für
mich super tropfen ist ja nur ein klick
und ja ich hoffe wir schaffen es noch
dieses jahr und herzlich willkommen zu
einem youtube video von mir wollte wir
befinden uns heute jetzt hier schon beim
dritten part vom xxl black friday
unboxing werden insgesamt zehn produkte
drei oder vier fehlen noch ich sehe
schon kommen einige in den kommentaren
werden wahrscheinlich die firma jetzt
rechts auch mal leute ich hab absolut
recht das ist jetzt wirklich das letzte
video praktisch das finale
und vielleicht hätte ich das doch besser
auf zwei parts aufteilen sollen dann
wäre es glaube ich ein bisschen cooler
geworden noch aber können wir halt jetzt
nicht machen weil der zweite platz ist
auch schon allein der erste band auf und
ich habe wirklich noch glaube ich vier
produkte hier rumliegen zum einen soll
hier den saugroboter aus china den ich
auf jeden fall noch testen wollte und
dann haben wir noch dieses paket und
dann haben wir noch ein etwas größeres
paket das hier kommt glaube ich sogar
ausnahmsweise von einem deutschen
hersteller werden wir gleich mal sehen
dass hier aber nicht okay und ich glaube
da ist was verrückt ist mal wieder die
sind ja schon wieder angeklopft hat
schon wieder ganz neue mails bekommen
analysiert herzlichen kontakt auf jeden
fall den ersten part okay leute dann
würde ich sagen mach ich mal den
reporter auf der schon ein bisschen voll
mit cola ist ich weiß nicht wie das
passiert ist und im hintergrund stehen
ja diese ganzen anderen sachen die habe
ich gestern bei linstow wenn man meine
story gepackt das heißt wenn jetzt
schnell seid könnt ihr noch offen ich
sowie antworten und in einer woche
kontaktiere ich dachte die haben wir
erst mal eine dicke beschreibung gut die
brauche ich nicht ich kann mich
eigentlich ich habe ja einen eigenen
saugroboter wird ja auch ganz stolz
drauf von chemie ich habe zum ersten mal
den namen dieser vier mal richtig
ausgesprochen
das habe ich immer gesagt zeige romy
nach grasse kümmert hier haben wir sogar
eine fernbedienung da kann man den
steuern und ich meine dann kann man
daraufhin apps
das hier ist dann die ladebox davon und
hier haben wir das gerät ja okay wir
hierhin dann haben wir hier eventuell
ersatz bürsten sowas ist auf jeden fall
super wichtig ich weiß gar nicht ob ich
das bei meinem eigenen habt meinen das
problem ist diese bürsten verfangen sich
sehr oft wenn auf dem boden irgendwie
ein haar liegt oder zu viele haare oder
ein kabel oder halt auch ein teppich ich
musste meine socken wurde schon so oft
aus diesem teppich raus ziehen weil sich
halt irgendwie immer verfängt aber das
aufhören habe das reicht erst mal ich
stelle ist wie finanziert zur seite ich
hab's glaube ich auch schon dem letzten
platz und sagt also checkt auf jeden
fall auch die beiden weiteren fahrzeug
etwas dingen hat den wert von 240 euro
glaube ich schaue und sofort nochmal
nach also dass sie ziemlich ähnlich aus
wie mein eigener hier so ist von vorne
aus und jetzt habe ich gerade gesehen
hier fehlen doch noch diese forsten die
muss ich da wohl noch einklemmen das
machen wir doch direkt mal das heißt wir
haben jetzt noch zwei ersatz bürsten
dann kann man hier also weiter an machen
und
jetzt achtet mal hier
genau machen wir schon mein tisch sauber
das wichtig der ist nämlich ganz schön
dreckig geworden
also ich muss sagen hört sich wirklich
gut an der natürlich sensoren dass er
hier nicht runterfallen kann das wäre
sonst natürlich ziemlich scheiße wenn
man den irgendwie im ersten stockwerk
fahren lässt oder dann die treppe runter
vor zählt aber gut also wir testen
gleich noch ein bisschen ausführlicher
unten im wohnzimmer da ich würde sagen
ich mach mal ganz kurz noch dieses
produkt hier auf das wollte ich mache
jetzt weiß ich was er zeigen wollte das
mal dass ein produkt was mir noch
gefehlt hat von tiffany wir haben hier
das zweite sex produkt oder wie man es
auch nennt sexspielzeug der bergfreie
wollen natürlich so wollen die tiffany
also nur leid
ja das packen wir gleich aus und jetzt
ist wird für 20 okay leute was geht
wären es schon ein bisschen später ist
so schon dunkel draußen ich habe mich
ein bisschen mit dem roboter beschäftigt
ist eigentlich ein gutes teil ich habe
ihn jetzt millionen unzen zu mal in die
ecke gestellt man hat er so eine
fernbedienung bei also es ist kein smart
roboter sag jetzt mal der mit laser
arbeitet und praktisch die wohnung ab
misst man sich dann halt auch über das
handy per app steuern
wir haben hier ganz simpel eigentlich
eine fernbedienung mit so ein paar
tasten hier kann man ihn sogar selber
steuern und ich habe ihn jetzt mal
programmiert der fette zum beispiel
jeden morgen um 10 uhr los wird euch
damit jetzt auch gar nicht zu viel
voller waren ich meine es auch ein
bisschen uninteressant ist ein cooles
teil ich zeige euch immer ein paar
einbildungen manchmal spinnt das ein
bisschen also ist nicht ganz perfekt
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
[Musik]
hier ist nur die idee gekommen weil man
ihn ja selber steuern kann
ich könnte mit dem er einfach über die
straße fahren so und dann zu gucken was
passiert was die leute die sich so
denken weil dieses video 7006 bekommen
mache ich das meinem video weiter hitze
drückt wollte jetzt geht's weiter
herzlich willkommen zurück ja das war
schon mal ein interessanter test jetzt
sind wir natürlich hier seid
wahrscheinlich alle nur deswegen haben
gebliebene vor allem die jungs das muss
man auch sagen ich habe auch gestern her
wo ist es dieses andere gerät was ich da
im ersten teil ausgepackt habe also
masturbation bachelor wie das halt auch
in meiner instagram sorge gepackt und
wir haben selbst zwölf jahre geschrieben
ich will dass haben brauche dringend so
gut sachen verändern sich nicht
naja dann schauen wir mal hier rein was
das hier ist ich bin gespannt sagt 7
master welchen ski wenn ja das hört sich
sehr vertrauenswürdig an
ja okay hier haben wir wieder auf
ladekabel das kann ich doch schon oh
hier hat man sogar dann sind wir immer
besser
hast du sogar so eine tragetasche wurde
das darin verstecken kannst damit man
das mitnehmen kann und hier ja es ist
etwas ähnliches wie beim ersten bad muss
ich sagen guck mal hier
hier haben wir dann halt wieder diese
gewisse öffnung und dann kann man das
hier starten glaube ich ja genau acht
hast es geht jetzt aber alle das produkt
im ersten paar das war leider leer und
jetzt vibriert das hier so kann man auch
stärker stellen
[Musik]
sogar mit sogar mit rüttelt funktion
alter krass ok ja höchst interessant
es stinkt ein bisschen nach plastik oder
so das sollte man vielleicht in form
gebraucht dann besser mal auswaschen
deponie wirklich danke mann du bist echt
die beste und die produkte von tiffany
sind natürlich ganz oben in der video
bestellung verlinkt tiffany vielleicht
sozis ich weiß du verstehst mir nicht
aber also alle meine daumen nach oben
dicken daumen nach oben für tiffany ich
könnte euch hier super gerne nochmal
eine mail von tiffany ist einfach
tiffany millionen englische of you have
more kölner express center tommi uhr
test eric singh vom you free because of
you
jetzt bin ich vielleicht aus dem konzert
gekommen wir haben noch eine waffe
seinen größeren karton
da wollte ich auf jeden fall auch noch
reingeguckt haben diesmal mit zeitung
verpackt hier haben wir ein bluetooth
led speaker also eine musikbox led
betrieben und ich meine der typ der mir
das geschickt hat sogar in deutschland
will jetzt auch nichts kaputt machen es
soll ja noch irgendwie bekommen von euch
am ende zumindest konnte der gut deutsch
und so mag
und dann holen wir das mal raus ich
glaube der beschreibung dazu brauche ich
erstmal nicht ja keine musik box also
ein standard bringen eigentlich die
leuchte dann auch wohl wahrscheinlich so
nach beat oder so kennt man ja kann man
hier dann glaube ich auch aktivieren und
ich würde sagen ich versuchte man zu
connecten dann steckt man mal den sound
up lange noch nicht so überzeugend aber
das heißt ja nicht mal tauchte schon
direkt auf direkt connected und jetzt
spiele ich mal irgendwas ab hat jemand
von euch ein bunt ich kenne richtigen
song thiago silva heißt er
[Musik]
sollte das auf jeden fall die vierte
stufe lauter die zwecks kummer und ich
habe jetzt gerade hier gemerkt man kann
hier die farbe wechseln indem man hier
auf oder zumindest dass das muster sag
ich mal wegsehen wenn man hier auf diese
lampe drückt der sound ist jetzt nicht
so überzeugend aber das gesamtpaket für
mich gut ich habe gerade mal nachgeguckt
das ding kostet ungefähr 25 euro wenn
man mal so unterwegs ist mit freunden
glaube ich ist das ne pulle entscheidung
so was zu holen pulver ok also leute ja
danke dafür und eine sache war
vr box virtual reality klingt aber wenn
man sich hier muss jetzt mein handy rein
hier kann ich als durch guckt man jetzt
sehe ich euch gerade und dass man sich
ja irgendwie wahrscheinlich eigentlich
mein handy da drinnen platzieren können
ach guck mal hier ich hier lerne ich
jetzt mein handy reit u
du kannst du mal aus malta da würde mir
richtig schlecht
leute ich habe jetzt gerade so ein video
an gemacht ich kann das jetzt hier
wieder gucken im groß war alter da wird
mir schlecht kasse es war irgendwie auch
ein bisschen unscharf so ganz habe ich
hier den sinn jetzt nicht verstanden was
man damit in vr box wolf juriatti ja gut
dass wahrscheinlich an so zum filme
schauen vielleicht auch zum zocken ich
habe keine ahnung also wenn ihr euch da
auskennt schreibt zwar in die kommentare
wenn aber auch danke dafür aber ich muss
sagen ich finde die musik besser vor mit
dem led geschäft mit den led leuchten
dazu ja dann würde ich sagen
leider habe ich nicht mehr das waren
jetzt insgesamt bestimmen 819 pakete
vielleicht hat sich das ganze jetzt auch
so ein bisschen langgezogen mit den drei
fazit ein bisschen leichter hier vor
allem jetzt bei dem letzten part ist
vielleicht noch unterhaltsamer werden
kann aber wenn man dann halt irgendwie
drei mal die gleichen sache in einem
partner auch wenn es andere coole sachen
dann ist es natürlich ein bisschen
langweilig das verstehe ich hoffe dieser
partner wieder ein bisschen besser
abonniert den kanal lassen da und wir
sehen uns morgen um 20 uhr wieder gibt's
neues video
haut rein